i
i wonder what you think about this whole
world of deep learning
from a perspective of uh theory
what do you make of this whole
discipline of the success of neural
networks of how to do science on them
are you excited by the possibilities
of what we might discover about neural
networks do you think is fundamentally
an engineering discipline or is there
something
theoretical that we might crack open one
of these days and understanding
something deep about how system
optimization
and how systems learn i am convinced by
is it tiger martin mit who's tag mark
yeah techmark right
so his notion has always been convincing
to me uh
that the fact that some of these models
are inscrutable is not fundamental to
them
and that we can we're going to get
better and better because in the end you
know
the reason why practicing computer
scientists often who are doing ai
or or working at an industry aren't like
worried about so much
existential threats is because they they
see the reality is they're
multiplying matrices with numpy or
something like this right yeah and and
tweaking constants and hoping that the
classifier
fitness yeah for god's sakes before the
submission deadline
actually like gets above something like
it feels like it's it's linear algebra
and and tdm right um but anyways
i'm really convinced with his idea that
once we understand better and better
what's going on from a theory
perspective it's going to make it into
an engineering discipline
so in my mind where we're going to end
up is okay forget these
metaphors of neurons and these things
are going to be get put down into these
mathematical
kind of elegant equations differentiable
equations that just kind of work well
and then it's going to be when i need a
little bit of ai in this thing
uh plumbing like let's get a little bit
of a a pattern recognizer with a noise
module and let's connect i mean
you know this feels better than me so i
don't know if this is like a reasonable
a reasonable prediction but that we're
gonna
it's gonna become less inscrutable and
then it's gonna become more engineerable
and then we're gonna have ai and more
things because we're gonna have a little
bit more
control over how we piece together these
different
classification black boxes so one of the
problems
and there might be some interesting
parallels that you might provide
intuition on is
you know neural networks are very large
and they have a lot of
it you know we were talking about uh
you know dynamic networks and
distributed
algorithms one of the problems with the
analysis of neural networks
is uh you know you have a lot of nodes
and you have a lot of edges to be able
to interpret and to control
different things is very difficult
there's uh
there's fields and trying to figure out
like mathematically how you form
uh clean representations that are like
like one node contains all the
information about a particular
thing and no other nodes is correlated
to it so like
it has unique knowledge and like but
that ultimately boils down to trying to
simplify this thing
into that goes against its very nature
which is like
deeply connected and uh like
dynamic and just you know hundreds of
millions billions of nodes
yeah and in a distributed sense like
when you zoom out the thing has a
representation an understanding of
something
but the individual nodes are just doing
their little exchanging thing
and it's the same thing with stephen
wolfram when you talk about cellular
automata
it's very difficult to do math when you
have a huge collection of distributed
things each acting on their own and it's
almost like
it's it feels like it's almost
impossible to do any kind of theoretical
work
in the traditional sense it almost
becomes completely
like uh like a biology you become a
biologist as opposed to
yeah a theoretician you just study it
experimentally yeah i
i think that's the big question i guess
right yeah is
so so is the large size and
interconnectedness of the
like a deep learning network fundamental
to that task or we're just not very good
at it yet because we're using the wrong
metaphor i mean the human brain learns
with much fewer examples and
and with much less tuning of the
whatever whatever whatever probably that
requires to get those like deep mind
networks
up and running but yeah so i don't
really know but the one thing i have
observed is that the
yeah there's a the mundane nature of
some of the working with these models
tends to lead people to think that to do
it like
it could be skynet or it could be like a
lot of pain to get
you know the thermostat to do what we
wanted to do and there's a lot of open
questions yeah in between there
you